la souris cherche un gendre conte
populaire chinois de cuisine aux
éditions souriant dans un grenier
abandonnée s'est installé un village de
souris de nombreux souris y vivent pas
renié elle une vieille souris du nom de
la mao
elle était très riche là où mao avait
une jolie fille qui s'appelait d'aia
elle était célibataire et de nombreux
garçons du village
désiré l'épousé lao bao ne savait pas
lequel était le meilleur
un jour là au mao eu l'idée d'installer
une estrade devant la fenêtre de la
daille à lancerait une balle et celui
qui parviendrait à l'attraper pour l
épouser toutes les souris du village se
réunir ou siffla ya ton pour fut amené
pour célébrer l'événement et encourager
les prétendants à s'emparer de la balle
dayya se tenait sagement sur l'estrade
regardant secrètement vers la foule
suite au pouvoir lancer la balle à celui
qu'a livré tout ce bruit réveille à un
petit chat qui dort mais par là se
passe-t-il à jeter un coup d'oeil le
minet curieux vite une petite souris
grâce qui s'apprêtait à lancer une jolie
balle non je veux la balle on abandonne
les souris pris peur et s'enfuir le
petit chat font ça sur laval dyad pu
éviter de tomber de l'estrade mais fut
rattrapé par une autre petite souris du
nom de à tous à tous l'emportant avec la
balle et s'enfuient après cette scène
épouvantable l'aoma au juge jacques
laisse aurait été trop faible un petit
chat à gâcher le mariage de ma fille je
dois lui donner un mari plus fort que le
chat il doit être le plus fort de la
terre actuellement qui était le plus
fort de la terre se demande l ao maohi
voilà la difficulté au même moment les
rayons du soleil frappèrent le visage de
l'aoma haut
et elle réalisa
et oui le soleil est le plus fort de
tous pas de soleil pas d'êtres humains
ni rien c'est cela ma vie devant elle
pesait le soleil immédiatement elle à la
rencontre du soleil l'aoma au grain pas
sur un arbre êtes vous le plus fort du
monde demanda-t-elle au soleil bien sûr
petit me dire qu'il n'a pas besoin de
lumière et de chaleur en ce monde
répondit fièrement le soleil oh oui je
souhaite que ma fille vous épouser vous
voulez bien avant que la roma aurait pu
finir un nuage passants et recouvrir le
soleil l'aoma ovi que le nuage noir
cachait le soleil et l 8i je veux marié
ma fille plus fort êtes vous d'accord
bien sûr vous avez vu que je peux cacher
le soleil p il n'avait pas terminé sa
phrase qu'une approche à sa main
une fois de plus la aux maldives
je cherche le plus fort au monde et je
veux que ma file épouse savez vous qu'il
est avec mépris le vent répondu bien sûr
que je suis le plus fort je fasse ce les
nuages
je balaie la poussière j'emporte les
feuilles je peux t'en portait également
émouvant porta haut bas haut dans le
ciel
là-haut mouse et des bâtis dans le ciel
soudain le vent se heurte à un mur et
disparus là-haut maoz tomba et senti que
le mur semblait être le plus fort elle
dit je voudrais que ma fille soit ta
fiancée et que tu les pouces bien sûr
que je suis le plus fort main me faire
épouser une souris se tapotant la
poitrine lemay a dit oum au pied le
groupe leurs acides 1 tandis qu'un
groupe se creuser dans son pied le vent
ne peux pas me déplacer la plus ne peut
pas m'abattre
seule une souris creuser un trou pour
m'enlever la vie c'est la souris qui
avaient sauvé d'aia qu'ils avaient
creusé le trou
enfin lao bao compris ck tout non j'ai
trouvé par hasard ce que je cherchais
partout et si loin
notre tribu est petit mais nous avons
des capacités supérieures aux autres je
te donne ma parole et tu seras mon
gendre l'âme tu au oui bien sûr répond
10 à 12 tout heureux
bientôt avec pétards fusées gonds et
tambours dai a finalement se financent à
aa tout depuis lors le 25ème jour du
premier mois de l'année lunaire
elle joue du mariage sous le signe de la
souris pour les chinois